بالنسبه لهذه المظاهره التي دعت اليها
جبهه الخلاص الوطني المعارضه انتهت قبل
نحو ساعتين من الان اما في ما يتعلق
بالشعارات التي رفعت خلال هذه المباراه
فان شعر اولا غير طاب سياسي تدعو الى رحيل
الرئيس قيس سعيد وايضا منظومته باعتباره
انه لم يحسن اداره الازمه السياسيه في
البلاد وايضا هناك شعارات اخرى اقتصادي
واجتماعي تتعلق اساسا بتدهر المقدره
الشرعيه وايضا نظرت المواد الاساسيه
والادويه هذا الى جانب تجديد الدعوه الى
مقاطعه الانتخابات البرلمانيه القادمه
لانها انتخابات المغشوشه وفقا اثار جبهه
خلاص ايضا رئيس وطني احمد نجيب كان القى
كلمه خلال هذه المظاهر هي كلمه لم تضم
طويل لكنه تعرض فيها اول الى موقع اجابه
خلاص الوطني من منظومه ما يسميها بمنظومه
الرئيس قيس عيد وقال انها ما رسلت
الانقلاب وبالتالي فان هذا الاحتجاج وايضا
الاحتياجات السابقه
في اطار محاوله دفع باتجاه رفع هذا
الانقلاب ايضا اعتبر ان المخرج من الازمه
السياسيه واذا الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
التي تعيش البلاد لن يكون الا من خلال
حوار وطني جامعه له حكومه انقاذ وطني
فاتنظيم انتخابات رئاسيه وايضا اا
برلمانيه السابقه لاوانهم مما ربما مالكه
في هذه المظاهره فايزه هو ان هذه المظاهره
كانت المفروض ان تتزامنه ايضا مع مظاهره
لخمسه احزان سياسيه ربما يكون العنوان هو
ان المظاهره ان ان المعارضه تتوحد لاول
مره في تونس بعد 25 هجريا 21 لكن الاحزاب
الخمسه كانت يوم امس تاجيل مظاهرته
وبالتالي فانه اليوم نزلت فقط اجابه خلاص
الوطني التي اكدت ايضا على لسان رئيس
الجبهه بما ان ال- مخرج من ازمه يتطلب
ايضا وحده التونسيين ووحده المعارضه وقال
ان هذه الوحده لن تتحقق في مظاهره اليوم
لكنها اكيد تحققوا خلال الايام